Speaker 1: So tomorrow or probably next week,
I will have a report for you about the legal
challenges that are already starting for the
midterm elections that are 12 days away. Yet
they're doing it again. There's no question that
they're doing it again. We've already seen a
number of legal challenge challenges start. And
if you want to sort of get a jump on that story,
you can Google it and you'll find some examples.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson is doing
something very dangerous. And I fear and I believe
that the fear is a very rational and sober fear. I
fear that they are going to be doing 2020 all
over again where they are priming the right
wing and the pro-Trump people are priming their
audiences and their voters to believe if we lose,
it must have been fraud. And they are priming
them to be angry to the point where they may again
become violent. Here's a clip from last night's
Tucker Carlson propaganda show on Fox News,
where he is in an overtly dangerous way,
starting to say, listen, some of these people,
if they supposedly when they definitely
didn't, then you should be ready for that.
Then he bling brings on Glenn GRift Wald to
talk about it, which we won't be looking at.
Speaker 3: And keeps working. It's not about
the person. It's about the party. It's not
about the individual. It's about the group.
And to prove it, they can even run mentally
defective candidates who can barely speak.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way, when he says
mentally defective candidates who can
barely speak, we know he's talking about
John Fetterman. But Fetterman is not barely
mentally defective. Fetterman had a stroke
and has an auditory processing issue. And it's
abundantly clear when you see Fetterman right,
that he can absolutely make the case,
as his doctors have, that he has his
mental faculties in place. Tucker should be
talking about Herschel Walker, but he's not.
But he's talking about Fetterman. Okay. Let's
continue with the video. I'll go back a moment.
Speaker 3: Mentally defective candidates who
can barely speak and only expect them to win,
but expect you to accept the outcome no
matter how transparently absurdities.
On November 9th, they'll be telling you that John
Fetterman got 81 million votes in Pennsylvania
and they'll threaten to put you in jail if
you don't believe it. Why wouldn't they do
that at work with Joe Biden? Glenn Greenwald is an
independent journalist. His work is on Substack.
Speaker 1: Yes, Substack. Okay. So candidates
that can barely speak, he should be talking
about Herschel Walker. He's talking about John
Fetterman. Tucker just makes things up and the
line that he is implicitly going with here
is elections we lose are rigged. That's the
name of the game. And this the groundwork was
laid in 2019 into 2020. They tried it in 2020.
They may have been able to get away with it in
some localized instances, which fortunately they
did not, but they got close enough to stealing
some electoral votes that of course, they're
going to try it again. And the name of the game
now is. If we lose, it was rigged. And if we win,
we say nothing at all. Look at what was happening
in the Arizona gubernatorial race, where it was
a close race. Cory Lake ultimately won. When it
looked like Carrie Lake was down by a little bit,
she and others immediately started with
the voter fraud claims irregularities here,
early voting problem, their mail in ballot problem
here and on and on and on. And then she ended up
winning by a little bit and they basically shut
their mouths about the fraud. If you ask them,
they do have a ready made explanation. And the
readymade explanation is, well, there was tons
of fraud and attempts to rig it. We just won by so
much that even with the fraud, we ended up winning
by a little bit. That's their explanation. And of
course it is un falsifiable. We are soon going to
be putting out a really good white paper guide
sort of thing. It'll be free to everybody in
our audience of how to approach people when they
make claims like this. How can you start and kind
of have a conversation where you agree on what
is it we're trying to figure out and how do we
determine what is the truth? And one of the things
that that guide is going to include is a sort of
not a warning is sort of sort of notice that
when the standard is one that depends on you
to falsify something that's not falsifiable, it's
not even really worth getting involved. And what I
mean by that is the voter fraud, election fraud,
it was rigged. People they can always say, you
haven't definitively proven to me that there was
no rigging. And of course, if there is no rigging,
it's hard to prove definitively that there was no
rigging because there is an absence of evidence
for rigging. That's it. Burden of proof has
been shifted. And so it's really important
to consider is the standard of proof that someone
else is putting out an impossible standard to me,
because I can go to them and say, okay, the
number of registered voters and submitted ballots
perfectly aligns with the state's population age
demographics. For how many registered voters there
could be historical turnout. That all looks
fine. The anecdotal reports of specific fraud,
double voting, dead voters, etc. We've run them
down and found that they are without merit.
So we have no reason to believe that there was
election fraud here. And they'll say, No, you have
not proven to me. What about that claim and that
claim and that claim and increasingly unbelievable
claims. So it's very important at some point to be
able to understand the burden of proof. You were
claiming something that is not supported by the by
the data and is an extraordinary claim that all of
the results we have reflect the wrong winner per
the will of the people. You have to prove it. At
some point. The burden of proof has to be on them.
And unfortunately, when Tucker just goes, listen,
they're going to make you accept that candidates
who can't speak got a ton of votes. It's just it
just doesn't work. He is priming these folks
dangerously to reject losses as fraud. And it
could it's we know it can get very ugly. Look
at 2020. Okay. Lawyers losing their licenses,
violence, deaths. Okay. We know it can get
very ugly and it may again get very ugly.